welcome back to new rock stars one
division's nosy neighbor agnes is acting
suspicious but like a weirdly different
kind of suspicious than everyone else is
kind of like someone at a surprise
birthday party who also clogged the
toilet like
i can't wait to see the look on her face
also that dump was there before i went
in
oh i see headlights so what the [ __ ] is
agnes deal
is she lying who is she lying to is she
lying to herself
i'm eric boss this is rogue theory with
me today is marina mastros hi
eric that was a crazy intro i feel like
that's sadness this whole thing
it's just that he doesn't dumps in
people's houses and not telling anybody
is awesome
yeah uh well we got a a quartet of upper
deck um
i almost had a quartet of upper deckers
but that's not what just
that's a whole other ball game say it we
got a quartet
of upper deckers here because the main
toilet's clogged you gotta put it
somewheres
uh no one knows that better than east
coast correspondent tommy beck told
hey hello eric everything is great here
there's nothing to worry about
we're having so much fun help me you
have to help me
no one listen to him no one help him he
has to learn on his own
and we want to welcome back to rogue
theory someone who's been working with
us more intimately
in recent weeks uh brandon barrack now
off screen
producer brandon of new rockstars what's
up guys sometimes i'm off screen
sometimes i'm on screen but much like
agnes i'm constantly lying to myself but
i'm happy to be here
all right so the four of us are gonna
try to figure this out together
uh what is agnes deal does she have some
kind of secret plan
so we went into this series almost
certain that agnes was actually the
witch agatha harkness
she began as this nosy neighbor who
seems to know more than she's letting on
about wanda
she has this off-screen husband ralph
who may or may not exist marinate
may not be mepisto she almost always
wears that brooch she had that weird
moment with the mailman
she turned wanda against dottie and
geraldine she shushed her
when he's about to tell vision because
we're all
something she's really eager to babysit
those boys and then shows up
with sparky the dog dead and then seemed
genuinely shocked to learn that wanda
can raise the dead
sword has been unable to identify her
true identity and now
dressed up as a spooky witch she
catatonically glitches near the west
view border
and upon awakening from vision she kind
of cries she pats herself she thinks
she's dead and she yells at vision that
he's a dead avenger
and then she drives off laughing
maniacally as one does after clogging
the bathroom toilet
now when she does get awakened
unlike other people who this happened to
like norm
abby lash she does not have a true
identity other than agnes she just keeps
responding to agnes
and then when vision found her before
this she could still kind of talk
unlike the completely frozen west view
residents so let's figure this out guys
why is agnes in west view what does she
want and i think we gotta start by
asking
did she want wanted to create this west
view hex or was this a kind of accident
that
trapped her inside as a victim i think
agnes wanted to do
something with wanda's magic but she
wasn't sure what was gonna happen so she
kind of set
wanda up to have some sort of crisis
or or you know relive her guilt and it's
drawing the magic out of wanda but agnes
isn't
exactly in complete control she's just
kind of rolling with the punches
so when things happen she has to adjust
and like play along and
keep things moving in the direction she
wants but ultimately she doesn't know
what the ending is going to be like so
she's just kind of uh
playing along now is that different from
everyone else in west view are they 100
victims we think
who are completely blindsided is herb
different than everyone else
one of the things that stuck out to me
and it was uh agnes conversation with
vision where she gets information from
him and then responds then all is lost
which is just a little like to me it's a
little too mystical it implies
like just to respond that way rather
than kind of like i don't know how a
normal person in 2020 or whatever would
respond like all is lost is just
it it it to me uh it uh
it implies something grander at stake
like she's got some sort of magical
power or at least is aware of the
magical world
in which uh wanda is playing off of so
i i like what brandon's saying i think
yeah i think she might be
another sort of magical entity that has
been trapped in here
and is now just kind of playing the long
game and waiting to see
what she can do to get herself free or
if she even wants to be free maybe this
is something that she encourages
so have you guys ever seen the craft yes
oh yeah light is a feather stiffer
support baby
there you go um so i think
sh this is the dumbest um this is the
dumbest theory
it's the rogus aka dumas um so she is
at the harkness that's why she still
responds to her name because it's like
close enough right
and um in if you if you guys remember
in the classic uh cult hit
actually it's probably just like an
overall successful
movie the craft what's the one thing
that makes
witches stronger like you can be a very
strong witch on your own but what's the
one thing that makes a witch stronger
and her powers like bigger
sisterhood
friendship right
kissing kissing yeah it is a comment
but saying sisterhood is so much better
and cuter
but yeah a coven right so so i think
she is from uh you know she was alive
during salem witch times which is why
she can't
uh there's no record of her because her
record of her birth would have been like
a piece of paper that's like
disintegrated a million years ago
and um that's how she's a million years
old
the salem witch trials were just like i
like that they tried to have
ids back in 1692 but like
they just did then there's one guy who's
got
nice penmanship writing all the making
all the ideas
when you get it
[Laughter]
i want mine illuminated god damn it okay
so she
so she uh i think she asks am i dead
because she watched all of her sisters
get burned to death right so she's like
oh [ __ ] did this happen to me
she wants the coven to come back because
she is a witch she has her own powers
which is why i think she's able to
speak sometimes on her own and ask wanda
like hey should i take this again like
what do you want
you're the director because she is a
witch herself
but she's not as strong as wanda and so
she's drawn to that energy i think wanda
started making
west view on her own obviously she
didn't intend to but then
agnes is drawn to that energy because
she is a witch and
she wants to keep other people from
shutting it down
because she wants her own coven and i
think
when she and i might be the only person
who read catherine hans acting this way
but
when she when wanda says that she can
bring people back from the dead
i read her acting as hopeful
as opposed to to fearful so in my head
i automatically thought oh she
now thinks she can bring her coven back
the rest of her coven that died at salem
she can increase her circle she can get
her friends back she can get her girls
back
and like i know we've been talking a lot
about mephisto
and all that but i i like the idea that
she's the agnes is just
doing this for herself on her own it's
like you know it's about sisterhood
um as brandon said sisterhood it's the
sisterhood
and she just wants her coven back and
she's drawn to that energy she doesn't
realize
how powerful though wanda is and now
once she gets sucked in
she is overpowered right like she is
she got in over her head but she
can still function a little bit so she
wants it to keep going
because she's probably benefiting from
just being around that
magic even if she is like sort of
overcome by it so basically it's just
the crap
i think that's a really good idea uh in
terms of what her
goal might be i'm wondering marina if
like
westview i don't know if wanda created
westview
alone i because then i'm wondering well
then why isn't she completely in control
of it i'm thinking that
you know agnes might have been there to
help wanda initially create
western yeah but like her reaction when
vision to awaken there was kind of like
a
coming up for air kind of thing like as
if like a magician
discovering their trick actually worked
on the other side of it i think she was
surprised how effective
it was and that's kind of like that's
why she has these moments of
cognition is she accidentally got sucked
into it um but like
there are these moments where she seems
like a victim and that's what's just
kind of hard to square
is or to hex i guess
i'm glad you brought up that moment
where she wakes up eric because i
thought it was really interesting
because
the only other person we've seen woken
up in west view was norm and he was
immediately like oh
my my sister we got to help them you
know he was like very dramatic
uh and very concerned and like panicked
but when agnes gets like woken up
she she grasps herself and she's like oh
am i dead and it's kind of overly
dramatic and maybe it's because you know
she's this supernatural being that's
lived through time she doesn't know what
it's like to be a real
vulnerable normal human so she's acting
like
a normal human like this am i dead
agnes oscar moment oh
this is
yeah and it's strange because why is she
so far away from town you know
is she pulling vision out away from
wanda trying to get him closer to the
edge of the hex for some reason
you know agnes is always doing these
things to kind of
force things on wanda you know she
brings sparky into their life
uh she sprays the twins with that like
lavender oil and suddenly they get older
so it's really strange to see her like
not in control and
in those moments when she's feels like
she's not in control she like kind of
freaks out a little bit
so i think this is like her big acting
moment on the edge of town
trying to make vision think you know
she's on his side of
whatever side this is uh but she her
master plan is still in effect and
it's still working in her favor or or
my friends is the reason
she reacts differently to being under
when she's kind of a catatonic
because she's not human yeah because
maybe she's an alien
maybe she's a shape-shifting you had me
right before aliens there's other
non-human things that she could have
been
like a spirit or a ghost or a zombie
and we've seen more aliens in the mcu
than spirits ghosts or zombies
maybe the reason that the magic affects
her differently is because she's not
she's something beyond human
beyond belief fact or fiction no we made
that up
concert like you're saying no 20 times
no
you idiot it was fiction that was false
why are you so stupid
that we're on our last season to this
right eric you did mention the broach
earlier where is
where is the approach it's been gone
that's what's broach gate where's the
brooch
the brooch thing is killing me guys
because like
most of the time we see her with it but
we don't always hear with it when she
was kimmy giblard up
where was that brooch you can't you guys
will never know how many times i click
through all that footage frame by frame
like is it tucked under her big frizzy
hair
is there a lump somewhere in those
spandex no brooch
and she was acting just like she does
every other time so how important is
that brooch and why wasn't it there
then is it not important maybe it's not
important maybe it's her
i mean eric you said in one of your
breakdowns that it could be like her
talisman and if she
if it is her talisman and she is
succumbing deeper and deeper into
wanda's control
then it could be that she doesn't have
it all the time with her because
it represents how in control she is or
isn't so she could be losing it like
literally it's not there as a
representation of her power because
she's losing her power over time
it is worth saying that when she did not
have her broach
when she was can be given loaded up is
when she's more likely to break
character so that that was the same
where she's like
you uh you want me to take it from the
top um and then she had that whole line
about like um
you know children you can't control them
right um whereas when she does have the
broach she seems to be more
in character so maybe there is some kind
of trance that helps her stay in
um i well let's let's ask ourselves this
guys
do we think agnes i mean marina your
theory is that
this is all tied back to her historical
roots and her coven
um yeah is she working alone with some
kind of plot like that
or does she have a partner is ralph or
you know
nightmare mephisto the grim reaper one
of these figures some silent partner
that she's serving
i know there's a lot of theories that
she is
working for or with someone else i
just am choosing to reject those okay
because
they all kind of like uh
hinge on like okay she's a servant of
mephisto she's trying to
help this other person out and they're
all male characters and i just don't
want that to be true
i just want her to like function on her
own and be her yeah
she can have her own set of traveling
pants she just wants i want her to be
her own person and have her own goal so
it's like yeah she wants her coming back
she wants more power she wants like to
build a more modern reality of witches
and bring witches back
into their full power before salem when
they used to be more of them and before
they all got roasted
to a toasty crisp um so i know
it's not like a popular theory and there
are a bunch of other ones that probably
are way more legit
but that's what i want i want her to be
pursuing her own agenda which is fine i
mean there's a version of this marina
where it could be like you know
agatha or agnes historically has a
partnership with some kind of a
supernatural entity
but this is the time where she's like
i'm going to use wanda to overthrow him
you know
she could still have an agency she can
still be you know
on her own agenda her own motives but
like yeah
you know that might require her to
dethrone the previous
uh demonic figure whoever it is you know
what go girl yes
yes thank you eric eric i know i know
you're big on mephisto
okay and you want to see mephisto so bad
uh but i really think that maybe
agnes is mephisto okay hear me out hear
me out you know the mcu
i think they're feeling powerful right
now you know they've had all these
successful movies now the successful tv
show
i think they're ready to throw a big
curveball at us and do a little gender
swap
and have you know agnes ago the hardness
actually be
mephisto herself you know it's time
they're ready they're the mcu is ready
to tell us what's what they're ready to
get
crazy they've had enough of the comic
book nerds telling them how things have
to be
they're going to tell us what it's like
now and i think it'd be really
interesting to see
you know mephisto be a female i love
that idea i think i can
i think kathryn hahn would crush that
if she was talking about it i'd love to
see her as a big bad in the mcu i mean
yeah when you think about it we're like
six episodes in and they haven't really
given us any big
clues that mephisto's gonna show up you
know there's been little hints and
dribbles here
like little things eric loves to pick
apart uh you know mentions of hell a
little fire and a little red
but really a mephisto out of nowhere
would be kind of crazy
and to quote marina i don't want a man
coming in taking this all away okay
i think i would love to see agnes be in
charge of the whole thing and she really
is mephisto and she's running
the show it would be unearned at this
point to have a man just come in
it's not about sisterhood you guys it's
about
mephister hood mephisterhood
mefister
[Laughter]
aka i can't have that seven hours of
movie and discussion with my mom back
ever please give me give me the three
hours of the movie in the four hours of
me and my mom trying to figure it out
back to me please give it back to me
christopher nolan reverse time that way
give me that time back so i wanna um end
by just
getting people's thoughts on what do we
think is the end game of agnes so
uh marina you brought this idea it is
she's just trying to reconnect with her
coven
but if she is herself one of these
demonic entities
or if she's working with someone or is
it really just for the children
are they just trying to snatch these
kids are they trying to
um steal wanda's powers uh are they
trying to create a
portal between dimensions so they can
unleash hell or some kind of demons into
our world
are they trying to open up the
multiverse like what is the
plot yeah i mean for me like i said
before i think she's just trying to
bring
power agatha's trying to bring agnes
agnes is trying to bring power back to
herself to restore her original power
and to raise the overall prominence of
witches
because wanden in the mcu
has been sort of a side character and
now she's the main thing
and and agnes can benefit from that so
for me that's
that's to raise the overall dominance
of witches with power i wonder if agnes
is trying to
draw the magic out of wanda through
these kids like she's using these
tommy and billy as manifestations of
wanda's magic
and she's gonna take them away because
ultimately
you know wanda's story is grief in all
the movies she's always dealing with
some form of grief
uh and now in one division she's
obviously dealing with a lot of grief
and i think agnes has weaponized that
grief and is going to use it to
steal wanda's magic by stealing these
kids because i don't think wanda gets to
leave
west view with the kids not she's not
leaving with vision and she ain't living
with the kids
it's going to be sad and it's going to
be tough and one is going to have to
work through that pain
probably in a pretty dramatic way yeah i
i like that idea
um like especially since these kids are
don't really seem to have a corporeal
physical counterpart
in that hex they were a product of the
hex so if
those kids are it's for the children
these kids have their own powers
that ultimately maybe they're waiting
for these kids powers to emerge
and we haven't seen agnes around these
kids when they have the powers yet and
maybe that's when she's gonna snatch him
up
gobble gobble oh yeah well so what so
what i'm wondering is
is it almost a thing where like whoever
agnes is and whoever she's working for
have they discovered that this section
of the world
kind of like how a lot of quarterbacks
come from pittsburgh is like
a section of the world where there are a
lot of kids
with potential to be uh to have
superpowers
so she needs to use wanda to unlock that
and are these kids the children that
will eventually become the students at
charles xavier's school for the gifted
like are these kids going to be saved
from agnes and whatever dark entity
she's representing
and and they become the first mutants in
the uh
in the in this universe obviously we
know that they're going to have mutants
from other
places come in but i think this could be
the way that that this universe has
mutants and maybe it's all a tie-in
to kind of introduce the x-men that way
i don't know just thought so then you're
saying that they make it past like they
don't
somebody doesn't steal them somebody
doesn't like uh absorb them
right a mercy doesn't absorb them back
into himself so that they actually make
it in your version
and then they just exist and they need a
place to go and they need to be
protected so who would protect them
well uh some really great points there
because it's still rogue theory i've
been uh scoring your points the whole
time
because i'm crazy
so brandon i liked your closing argument
there about how
this might be uh just using these kids
to manifest that magic
that uh agnes wants and it being all
about uh wanda's grief
so you're getting one golden sparkle
buck there i'm a pro i'm a pro
um marina you came out strong with that
coven theory and i love bringing more
witchcraft in there
so you get a point tommy you start out
in the hole with just saying aliens i
didn't know where you were going with it
but boy oh boy did you come in strong by
bringing in mutants not because i think
every mutant in the mcu is going to have
a jersey accent i would love if that's
the case
uh instead i do think this hex is going
to be
how the mcu establishes the existence of
mutants maybe
it spreads outward it grows and grows
and grows and it just triggers the
genetic uh conditions of certain people
to finally activate that
x gene so they now become mutants we'll
see i assume that's where you're going
so i'll give you a goal
right there but hey guess what tommy you
gotta back up one for him a fister hood
that's some pretty good word
yes
eric why are you rewarding him for that
i want more i want more positive
reinforcement
but fister fister never knew how much i
miss you
well the other big mystery from this
episode is where the hell did wanda get
these kids for the trick-or-treating
episode
we're gonna ask ourselves that but first
we want to thank some people who helped
us make this episode
starting with our good friends at blue
chew so blue chew
is making waves and bringing more
confidence to the bedroom
or to the any room you want to have sex
bluechu is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra
or cialis but in chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost
so it's not going to chew up your wallet
either uh there's no teeth on this one
if you're just trying to gum gum it down
you can do it i think you need some
teeth to chew right you can't just
gum a chewable how does i
i'm an idiot you can do a lot of drums
this is why i don't improvise
anymore bluetooth tablets combat
all forms of ed and can help men gain
extra confidence for when it is time to
perform
blue chew is an online prescription
service so no visits to the doctor's
office no waiting in the line of the
pharmacy it ships right to your door
and a discreet package sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days
bluetooth licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredient
and strength for your prescription don't
like swallowing pills
no problems here blue juice tablets are
chewable
blue juice tablets are made in the usa
and it's cheaper than a pharmacy so if
you could benefit from extra confidence
when it's time to perform
visit bluechew.com for more details and
important safety information
and we got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth for free
when you use our promo code rogue at
checkout just pay the five dollars of
shipping that's bluechew.com promo code
rogue
to receive your first month free and we
thank blue chew for sponsoring this
episode
we're just gonna thank our friends at
stereo so new rockstars is excited to be
partnering with the app stereo on
three new weekly live shows all three
shows are on the stereo app
live and you can download stereo for
free at stereo dot com slash new
rockstars
on mondays our editors are dissecting
some of their favorite moments from the
week of videos on wednesdays
philip and i go through the week of
entertainment news on fridays jessica
clements and i do our live inside marvel
one division after show
that you can hear hours before it
appears on youtube in that show jessica
and i stick around and answer more
listener questions
last week we got to interact with a lot
of listeners from all over the world
answering questions hearing your
theories and we love doing that q a so
much you're gonna see it on youtube much
later
so you get to be a star by uh joining
stereo
and talking with us you're gonna get
some screen time you're gonna get some
screen time
so you can access all these live shows
share your questions and theories and
interact with us
in real time by downloading the free
stereo app at stereo dot com slash new
rockstars that's stereo dot com
new rockstars and we want to thank
hellofresh for sponsoring this episode
hellofresh is america's number one meal
kit
hello fresh cuts out stressful meal
planning and grocery store trips so that
you can enjoy cooking and get dinner on
the table in 30 minutes or less
hellofresh's easy eats offering has tons
of quick and
easy meal solutions low prep recipes
and quick breakfasts and lunches that
are perfect for a busy schedule
i use hellofresh i really appreciate the
speed and efficiency of it we're super
busy right now pumping
out all these monovision videos so i
don't have a lot of time to shop and
cook and
what spare time i do have i don't want
to waste so
hello fresh gets me everything i need
for a delicious meal no waste of time
wandering
days through the pantry like someone on
the wrong side of ellis avenue
hey hello fresh offers the flexibility
you need with customizable orders every
week
you can easily change your delivery days
or food preferences and skip a week
whenever you need
do yourself a favor and help support new
rock stars by checking out hellofresh
go to hellofresh.com 10 rogue
and use the code 10 rogue for
10 free meals including free shipping
that's hellofresh.com
the number 10 rogue and use the code 10
rogue for 10 free meals all right
back to wanda vision knuckleheads uh the
first five episodes
were very clear about something westview
is for the children yet
it is devoid of children vision even
called it out
billy and tommy seem to be the first
kids to pop up in this town but in
episode six
the halloween episode wanda filled this
place with kids
pietro asked her about the kid
specifically he got this interesting
look on his face
suspecting that these kids might have
just been asleep in their beds in west
view not woken up until
now but wanda never actually answers his
question she just kind of acknowledges
that her hex over all these people is
wrong
so what changed where did wanda get
these kids
just the question yo where did she get
where did she get all these kids from
central casting
eric i i don't want to make everyone
uncomfortable but when a wanda
and a vision are very much in love there
is a way
they can express themselves uh
and if that love and expression is
successful
uh instantly wanda will become pregnant
and
will have a child within 24 hours uh
those
children are you saying she she rapidly
shout out all a hundred kids well i
wouldn't be that crass marina i would
say she birthed
through her glorious birth canal uh 1
000 children
no i i i think they were probably all
under a spell they were probably all
sleeping and then once i think wanda's
big thing is when she becomes aware of
other people's awareness she makes
adjustments right like whenever she's
under threat
of the jig being up she adjusts things
so she got called out for the fact that
there are no children so
a part of her you know that's not
participating in the in the moment
uh tv show element woke the other
children up
uh and they they got up from their beds
put on halloween costumes and
made mischief in this version you're
saying that so
maybe it's been like 72 hours that the
west view hex has been operational
yeah so do you think those kids that
they were just like laying in their beds
in this west view town
as reality was warping around them i
think they were frozen in time the way
that everyone
the way that the neighbors and the
outskirts are i think they were kind of
just oh like you're sleeping beauty
yeah yes yes just like sleeping beauty
my favorite of all the disney people
coming in this
yeah are they pissing themselves getting
bed stores yeah
i don't know how much time you guys have
but uh i believe that the magic
slows down slows down their
physiological needs as well
the way that the cap was able to be
preserved in ice
all of those years without needing
nutrients he
simply froze it in time i just want to
know some no go ahead god
no no no i i definitely want to know
based on based on what you're about to
say
i'm guessing it sounds like it's going
to be horrific so
dude two years but then i'll tell you
after
oh no i just think i think probably no
no no no i think part of the like frozen
in time element of the magic also means
that like
their hearts probably aren't beating
very fast and they're you know they're
not they don't they're not like
digesting in need of nutrients as fast
they're moving
super slow almost the opposite of the
the speed that
pietro has time is slowed down to where
minutes can take hours much like me
getting this point across is taking too
long
it's now way too long
whereas it could have been much shorter
okay but tommy
like you i i i've been on new rockstars
long enough that
i'd like to include real science when
it's applicable real life real world
science
and tommy you're not wrong because there
is a salamander and i believe it exists
in china
i someone fact-checked me but i watch a
lot of nature shows
there is a salamander that hibernates
and slows its body down
and it stops digesting it stops kneading
it stop using the rest
using the restroom is a salamander
little tiny salamander restroom excuse
me i need to go to the potty
anyone in here yeah yeah uh
and it and it shuts down its body and it
can stay um
like in that hibernative state for years
so that's real science tommy you know
it's me this is you guys are full of
[ __ ] no they are not
lizard boys and girls those kids are
because here's the deal here's my
follow-up to
this why wouldn't she just uh puppet
these kids to be awake from the get-go
why would she be like you'll stay in
your beds until i need you maybe it's
harder for her maybe it
requires more concentration to control
all of those people i mean
are there kids in east view you know is
there some sort of weird like
shelbyville springfield thing where you
know east view hates western yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
there's pawnee and eagleton yeah she's
like those pieces of [ __ ]
capital of the world shelbyville you
know maybe if east view is real
wanda like pulled these kids out of east
view and had them like
walk into the hex you know maybe that
was that alarm going off in that one
episode was all the kids
running in uh running into west view
like she's some sort of like pied piper
and called
yeah yeah west view is like a retirement
village no kids allowed there but east
view is a family town
so they got to check and cheese and
everything there's also the idea you
know
they've established that like wanda can
transfer matter from one thing into
another thing so maybe these kids
running around in this halloween episode
aren't really kids
maybe they're just like ants or
something that wanda turned into
children
i mean we never even hear any of these
other kids talk so who knows how capable
they are
and if you look in that episode there's
a lot of people in costume
and there are some kids running around
but there's a lot of adults like i was
always looking around i was like i'm not
seeing a ton of kids like she said she
made kids but yeah
i don't see that many kids but there are
there are legitimate kids there but i
think they just might be
full-grown ants in a kid's body it's
it's weird
every every time she goes up every time
you interact with one of the kids they
just say
i'm very busy i don't have time for this
and then scurry along
yeah they're all like manny from modern
family they're like
your words have been written by an adult
in this video yes
did you guys see the new cinderella the
like a remake of the cinderella with um
it's like the new version or whatever
randy that's the best version
that's the best version no i forget the
actress's name but they redid it in like
fairly recently but that they you know
obviously they have they turned the
little chameleons into like the
chariot drivers and they're like that's
cinderella's
uh no but they they deal with the fact
that they turn an animal into a human
and so none of those people can like
talk really they're all kind of stupid
and at first if you ask the chariot
driver a question he's just like
[Laughter]
blizzard
my skin exploded you guys remember that
nightmare fuel
[Laughter]
um that's a very good point uh we're i
think we're getting closer to
it because brandon do you have a good
point there about how the adult to kid
ratio is
way off like on halloween you need one
parent or
older sibling to walk the kids around
all of these families seem to have like
the parents there the uncles and aunts
the grandparents to their one kid who's
walking them around
yeah and then there's a bunch of
teenagers and it also looks like it's
1pm
uh eric i have a different like answer
to why
she didn't pull in any kids before i
think it's because she
is she knows it's wrong she said it's
wrong in this episode
and she feels bad doing that to children
all the way up until what like brandon
said she got called out
for it so she was like okay [ __ ] like i
finally have to do it
um and i asked my friend frank moran
for help for this and he and i think
he's right about what he thinks
um he says that wanda is a nexus being
okay and nexus beings have the ability
to affect
the universal time stream so his idea
and i think he's really right is that
when brandon says she got called out for
it
ins because she thinks it's morally
wrong to do this to children
she reaches through to another parallel
universe or another version of herself
and yanks through children from a
different dimension and
that's how she got her own children so
because for herself
vision never died she gets to live this
happy life so she just
reached through to this parallel
universe and she was like those are my
kids anyway i'm just gonna borrow them
and so she did that for the children too
because she's like well [ __ ] i don't
want to like
be terrible to these kids it's morally
wrong but like those parallel universe
kids
they're all gonna die in an asteroid
strike in two years anyway
she rick and morty them from another
universe essentially right
yeah so she pulls them in and because
she has that ability as a nexus being
well trash children from a trash
dimension
we're doing you a favor kids yeah
they're gonna get hit by an asteroid
anyway
you know there's a lot of talk that uh
there was like a spider-man three set
photo
where there are flyers of like mysterio
mysterio was right
you know and then there's also just
random flyers who are missing children
and it's like well we just had the blip
are we doing another missing kids plot
maybe that's like from another dimension
and this
that's where those kids were taken from
marina yeah also if you guys ever see
missing 4-1-1 it's a documentary it's
crazy and it's not necessarily about
aliens but it is how people go missing
and it's like you watch that and the
only answer is that they got sucked into
a parallel universe it's
nuts that's the only answer to all of
life's questions as far as
now i want to ask you guys i mean the
theory that i just kind of barfed out
in the uh breakdown was that kids might
be
dead that these might be the spirits of
children because it is all hallows eve
you know that's when the spirits walk
the earth could
that is that too dark for disney plus no
i think she
if they especially if they get a second
chance at life temporarily and it's a
fun holiday and it's halloween so like
that
is when they would be the most spirits
would be the most active i actually do
think that
part of the reason the kids have come
out i think all of the supplementary
magic not to not to blend two points
together
i think she's getting help i think she's
getting magical reinforcements from
agnes or something else i think
the children you know in the car and the
comic books wicked and speed rhonda gets
them from
making a deal with mephisto right isn't
that basically how the kids are come to
be
yeah unknowingly unknowingly she kind of
just yeah the kids just appear
and then it was like master pandemonium
puppeting them and then later it was
like no these were pieces of mephisto's
soul
weird guys but so you know
it kind of what the mcu does is take
like really weird comic points and then
make them like
simplify them and not make them as weird
so maybe
every child including billy and tommy
uh are all uh put there by agnes or put
there by some other you know what i mean
like there's another force that is kind
of like
filling in the gaps that wanda can't
control or doesn't control
you know the thing the things about west
virginia that
that throw people off there's another
some
someone someone or something that wants
wanted to continue this
is helping her and maybe the children
are manifestations of that
those are agnes 14 children back from 14
12 or whatever back when you used to
have 13 kids
yeah i wish we could get back to that
yeah we'll see if kids come back
next episode there's a lot of theories
that uh i mean
people have found some leaked audition
tapes these aren't leaks these are just
audition tapes in which kids read sides
anyway so i don't have a problem talking
about them
just skip ahead if you're worried about
it but really it was one of the child
actors
reading the scene in which he's being
bullied by another kid at school
honestly i think this was just to like
gauge his emotional range as you often
do with sides that never tells you
what's going to be an actual script
but i don't know if kids are going to be
back next episode in which case
these kids may have just been temporary
as to use brandon's term npcs they may
have just been set dressing
and that's why like when vision got a
closer look at them and on the other
side of town that you know that little
ruth bader ginsburg was like
you know the kids were not moving so
he's just kind of like oh these aren't
real and he just like pushes them over
and
they're flat and they fall over we'll
see
if kids come back okay i'm gonna award
some points here
uh uh marina you had a good thought uh
you're gonna get a golden sparkle book
but you have to share it with frank
moran
i will i will hey frank moran
i love frank moran tommy i will give you
a point for
the pain lizard driver
kill me no you'll get a you're not tied
up tommy's got three points tommy's in
the lead
damn it but it's still anyone's game
with
rogue questions uh so we got one
question disney plus has announced a
slate of european focus content
for the surface when it launches in
those countries
so i want you three to pitch me on how
you would make the mandalorian
or wanda vision more inviting for a
european audience
if you're gonna make a european version
of one division they'd have to have an
episode that was like a panel
show where like six people from the mcu
go on and tell stories some of them real
some of them fake and everyone has to
guess which story is real
and they award points but it doesn't
really matter and the show's called
something like
too many stones in the infinity gauntlet
um
yeah they love panel shows in europe i
don't know why they're not funny
oh my god get them get them
it's the mandalorian but instead of um
instead of
going around on spaceships everywhere
it's just trains
it's very efficient very quiet you get a
euro pass everywhere it just goes all
around the universe and and most of the
show is just
people quietly reading sounds european
to me
it is they go on trains everywhere man i
have a great picture of me
on the uh your rail uh next to a little
asian man who is so uncomfortable
because these trains are so small
and i'm massive and he's just sitting
next to me so unhappy
and my friend instead of you know
creating uh helping the situation just
kept taking pictures of us
sitting next to each other so that's a
happy memory uh
not good for the show nothing let's see
how do we make this european oh
oh this is so easy uh just i
uncircumcise all of the male characters
get them down you have to put a lot more
nudity in all of the shows and um well
tommy you get the point for that one you
are the winner of this weekend
thanks everyone uh well done wants
this this time you get this
no one knows what wins this um
that is it for this episode of rogue
theory
thank you so much to our guests marina
mastros tommy beck told brandon barrick
follow all three of them on social media
support their projects show them some
love
and you can support our channel by
checking out one of our many great merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com
like this unusual couples shirt i'm
wearing with all of its ar
hidden easter eggs one of them might be
a new rockstars team member
shirtless i don't know i've never
actually done it myself i just assume
that someone's going to want to put a
shirtless shot of himself in there
follow me which one would that who would
that be
who would that be i wonder which one
bobby
which obviously is
it mastertainment i don't know tell me
which
who would be shirtless maybe
so yeah follow all these people get get
our shirts join us on patreon
uh where you can join our official
discord server a lot of fun
conversations happening there you can
follow me at eavos follow me rockstar
subscribe here on youtube and remember
to download
the stereo app by going to stereo.com
new rockstar so that you can listen
to our three new weekly live shows uh
you can download the app for free on
apple and android and create an avatar
and profile
uh be sure to download now so you can
submit questions to one of our upcoming
shows
just go to stereo dot com slash new
rockstars and we'll see you next time
bye everybody me
[Music]
you